yeah sleep with different people so in
that let's say it's been like a year
since you've really embraced that how
many people would you have slept within
that year yeah give us some numbers uh
probably
300 Jesus in one year would that be the
average or is there like a big lump sum
in one session oh in a day five in one
day all right guys got a banger of an
interview right now with
the ain't no way Mom man said that with
a straight face he knew he know he knew
he knew what he was doing he KN he he
said it with a straight face though he
got a good Pok doesn't matter doesn't
matter that means that if the joke
that's that's if the joke don't land I
just said something if it lands I made a
joke with a straight face that's it it
wasn't premeditated I before the 300
people in a year I think my body count
was like 12 um and I was like you know I
haven't had that much sexual experience
I had an only fans at the time I was
like starting to be a bit more sexually
open trying new things like it was more
of like a me thing just to like explore
myself I guess and then and it's so
funny that like I explored Myself by
letting others explore my
insights yeah someone you know in order
to explore yourself you have to you know
hire a little Jacko to go in the death
of your yeah and his 3 299 bodies to
come through as well 399
custos that is a lot of exploration
going into your a lot of submarines but
yeah I never expected any of this to
happen and it definitely was plan which
is insane so is that 12 people total or
12 people per year prior to this you
said 12 people was that like 12 total
and then you went to three 12 people
yeah 12 people total and then 300 okay
so now let's get into the juicy stuff
here because okay so first and foremost
here like because I got to ask a lot of
people are asking DM because we have a
rating system I'm able to kind of gauge
you know guys are able to gauge I'm
married now I don't gauge anything by
the way nothing nothing so happily
married
um you look like you're lying I don't
know what it is you're lying about but
you sound
suspicious whatever you said you didn't
do I now believe you do and your wife
should be made
aware did he not sound so guilty yeah
you know guys have I would never I'm
married now so I would never do that but
like you know guys you sound a bit sick
about doing that like that but it is
what it is now doth protest a little too
much so as the homie Shakespeare would
say I don't want to plagiarize oh that's
homie shakes that's the homie
shakes hey Spears was killing it back in
the day yeah he was putting on them
plays
spey the homie Shake spey yeah Shak P
what is your rating system when you're
going through you know picking the 300
is it like they got to be a seven and up
what's your rating of a seven have you
lowered your standards to get to the 300
because like again if you have that
volume I would think quality would go
down what what's your criteria here N I
am seriously picky like I would not go
below a seven obviously personality is
probably more important to me but if it
is just going to be a one night stand
then I would rather go off looks because
at the end of the day we're not going to
be doing that much talking so yeah I I
would never drop AOW because it sounds
like you're picky but out of the 300 if
if you really like somebody I would
assume that that person would probably
be with you and dating you to some
degree or you just don't want to date at
all yeah I think like honestly it's
crazy because my criteria is very simple
I want a guy who's loyal family
orientated um kind non-judgmental um
intelligent I think intelligence is like
a really important thing for me someone
who's like just like equal to the way
that I think and also my moral like a
lot of people say I don't have any
morals but I do um so someone who's like
on the same page as me with that so
they're not that crazy but it is really
hard to find a loyal honest nice guy
these days um places maybe you're
looking in the wrong places I'm pretty
open-minded any woman sleeping with five
dudes in a day I'mma think she got
problems unless it's your job which even
then you probably have drw problems for
doing that job I just like kidding five
[__] in one day you can be openminded
openminded as much as you want five five
people in a day is exhausting I don't
care how much you like it I think most
people look at that and if that was a
dude in your place they'd be like he's
an addict a guy that does five girls a
day in what in one
day that's crazy that's a lot I'm
hearing all this stuff and as
open-minded as I am you need to meet
someone way more open-minded than me and
I feel like I lean pretty far more
openminded than most men I know sure
cuz most men I know here girls got a
high body count and they lose it or they
not with it yeah it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be that I don't think I know
any guy personally who would hear a girl
did 300 dudes in one day in one one year
and they would be cool with five in one
day is crazy to me you ask
any X workers and and and she she when
she's doing that she's not she's not
charging for that she just goes about
doing thing right so when you ask any ex
workers if it's a problem for them to
find someone everyone's going to tell
you yeah it it it is a problem yeah it
is going to be difficult to find someone
it's not going to be easy to find
someone that's going to be able to be
like yeah no that's cool but yeah I'm
ready I'm ready to settle down I'm ready
to find someone um I'm not just out here
to you know [__] people over or anything
like that like I do want to settle down
and I want to have a family no see okay
was wantong people say I'm ready to
settle down I'm ready to do this I'm
ready to do this you can't be settling
it down when you [__] five dudes in
one day you can no you can't you ain't
got time you ain't got time to get to
know anybody you ain't got time to
really invest yourself in somebody
you're too busy entertaining everything
else even trying to date multiple people
seriously is incredibly difficult it's
timec consuming managing a real job
managing your own business and trying to
[__] somebody you every day you not
going to do it you not going to do it so
people say here talking about oh my God
I'm ready to settle down and be serious
and be family oriented you just went
from the most hedonistic lifestyle and
you think you just going to turn it off
like a switch I say this thing to dudes
all the time dudes you think like I'm
going to keep [__] around and doing
everything I want and I'm going just
meet someone the next day it's all going
to work out that's not how it works you
can't just undo a lot of the habits that
you built the kind of dopamine Rush that
You' built into your brain of
discovering somebody new and think you
could automatically switch and be ready
for that lifestyle of like extreme
discipline that's that's not it's not
the way the human body works you've
literally built like new Pathways
whenever you're messaging somebody new
and you're getting into that and you're
getting that first You're Building that
repetition in your brain you think you
don't turn that off and you're not going
to be staring at other people you won't
be extremely tempted to do other things
that you're not going to have those
instant messages from all the women that
are already still ready to [__] you cuz
you've linen them all up you're not
building yourself to be a prospect to
somebody who's ready to do that stuff
it's like somebody who wants to be like
all right I'm ready to go sober let me
down three more bottles of Henny before
I finish up that's not the way you you
get off an addiction you don't get off
on addiction by just instantly going
cold turkey for most people that leads
to really bad relapse for vast major
majority of people and they start going
at it again and again and again again
when in fact the odds of failing are far
more likely than
not and what are you going to do while
you wait Sausage Fest this the same
thing it's so you're still going to be
there so now not understand I 100%
understand what you're saying when
you're saying that yo you're not setting
yourself up dick going down her alley
okay they just going to be flying bro
just anything you can find just I'm
waiting baby hey where where's my
where's my husband at where's he at oh
my God I'm so patient there's another
dick hey yo y you know them women just
be stop flinging stop flinging
dicks
stop
sorry stop being childish but I I
understand what you're saying if but
while you wait are you going to yeah
could you imagine if I'm looking at a
girl and I'm thinking approaching her
and all of a sudden I see dicks flying
by our head I'm like yeah
know yeah yeah yeah like I'm rolling up
to a bit place and some dude just
popping out like oh enjoy your turn I
don't know that's a little bit too much
for me two tap on the
shoulder your turn
buddy imagine if there's like wrestling
ropes and the [__] comes out tag
team let's go and I just
go tag me in
brother tag me in
um but yeah the right person hasn't come
along yet so I'm just going to keep
waiting I I definitely wasn't doing it
for virality it wasn't it wasn't for
anyone else but for me I just wanted to
experience lots of different people like
I said I'd been like pretty I don't know
like nonsexual beforehand so I just
wanted to I'm like I'm young I want to
experience life you know I'm turning 27
this year I feel like while I'm young I
should go out and have fun and I don't
think there's anything wrong with what
she's saying you want experience you
know do little exp that's fine you don't
you want to dab on some drugs great
don't start doing
myth you know don't be like oh I want to
try new things heroin
no that's not a new thing there's some
things you don't come I TR you think
murder no 300 bodies that's meth that's
meth for your dating life you look like
you got holes and sores all over your
body they're not there but they're in
everyone's brains when they think of you
as a
wife I see the my girls doing meth for
dating so I just want to say it's okay
to try and new things a little
moderation doesn't hurt either I think I
want to take this time to like really
explore lots of different people before
yeah I am ready to settle down and get
married and with the same person for the
rest of my life so it was just like for
me I don't know I just every day would
wake up and like okay well who am I
going to go on a date today there's a
lot of people that whenever to get to
with in the dating apps and of stuff
like that one thing that you see often
is people want to have they want to meet
someone that has no baggage or all their
baggage is dealt
with your baggage is public yeah but
your your your baggage is public that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about the fact that your baggage not
being your pum pum but what you have
behind you but now it comes with public
it's public it it comes with
broadcasted publicly
broadcasted luggage and that's people
people going look at it like okay so
what is the goal next year so 300 are we
going for 400 are we going to start
bringing it down and started kind of
honing in on finding the right
guy I think now it's changed a little
bit I what I call my regulars which are
like a it's like eight to nine people
that I sort of will rotate with I guess
that sounds so bad but they know about
what I do and who I am um so they AG
great to it and yeah it's just like you
know if I'm chilling in bed I'll message
one of them they'll come over and maybe
the next day I'll have another one over
and I'm glad that we talked I just had
so many questions based on situation I
do love the fact that you went viral
would I have liked if you went viral for
something else from a personal
standpoint yes but uh I genuinely wish
you the best honestly and I appreciate
you coming on and answering the
questions openly and honestly and it
means a lot thank you no thank you thank
thanks for having me I appreciate it
thanks Annie and uh go follow her Annie
k n ght so yeah things are opening up
and maybe you know we'll see in a movie
or something like that down the road
a my man said we'll see you in the movie
no my man said I hope things open up
they already open but but he said we see
she got films up on on on the Hub I'm
sure you can check her own leense
[Laughter]
all right my thoughts on this is a
sickness of the highest
order I don't he proof this woman has
been lost I think that I don't care
about what you do when you do it though
you have to understand what ramification
it does to you your psyche and your
health it's just that it it it it
as long as you understand
that do you I don't have to approve or
disapprove [__] I ain't your dad but you
have to and you should do you but you
know to anything that you do there are
consequences okay all right that's it
for today's video